see who's gonna make a unique wrestler
that is gonna take on GameSpot's
wrestler that we made nice ideally I
would love for this guy to come out
looking exactly like Mike Lai's if
that's possible
well it's possible if you could if you
can make this guy with the exactly right
Michael Hayes I'll buy your coffee
downstairs is that Michael well there's
different there's different there's
different styles of life it's just got
like 86 days and then we got 90 through
is it's different there's different
Michael Hayes is in this game so it's
Michael hair it's pretty close actually
that's that's that's that's warrior
though good out who the other one I'm
thinking I right there and that's it 16
its to blonde bro well then let's tow
him down get a little brown is brown it
looks like his hairs on the fire we need
fusion anything yeah you need that
7 o'clock shadow it's seven o'clock
shadow my class depends of time of the
hit is broke
like 2 o'clock 2 o'clock little
handlebar ski
you know cup 5 7 o'clock yeah good yes
bad breeze and good you guys suck
alright this is where it gets a little
awkward if Michael ever watches this we
have to do is this body mouth now I know
that you know Michaels body so you just
tell me ya little happy face right there
so you don't have to do exactly Michael
all right so this is Michael this is
Michael that's the one this my left arm
is symmetrical is my right well I think
so no tattoos thanks back not that you
know he had sunglasses right
well I mean yeah that cowboy hat you put
the cat on prop this is our this is our
world we're in charge of this world
which glasses we doing that's a Michael
that's a right there
it was nice 711 shades on the way to the
show realize you didn't pack your
sunglasses stop at 7-eleven buy yourself
a pack of gum and some rain gear
yeah I'm saying exactly what those are
the breeze not for sure oh it's a good
game this year yeah good game nice okay
he's home right now let's go that's
pretty sweet
that's kind of Michael ish dad is yes
mine oh those are cool round
thanks man he's getting them I'm making
an executive decision we can put a horse
head on didn't leave anything else go
not did it you we could make we can make
Michael a samurai if we wanted to
you got a name this gonna name this guy
I remind you we're not making Michael
hey no we're not
this is nothing to do with Mike what is
his name Mitchell Mitchell
Mitch Mitch Hazen bird nice ship afoot
Mitch Eisenberg MA
I'll know it when I see it Oh shy girl
[Music]
shy girl Mitch he's voting that's all
yeah no I see it that's good
respectfully disrespectful what do you
think Mitch though not
persevering or desperate desperate kind
of excited to test I really like Mitch
Hazen burger [ __ ] is a burger
Mitch Hazen burger that doesn't make you
laugh you're not a human being nice you
just feeling it dude uh-huh
watch out now it's nice to be no I
shaved my armpits but I've got become
I'm French in American yes
oh my gloves those ropes really yeah
Mitch's athletic dude we couldn't sell
those seats
Orlando no no no Mitch is good because
there's no Chad we could just work out
top bit oh yes right oh this must really
a sad dude looks really why is he so sad
does he see you know is he's a heavy
drinker looks like some already punched
him in the face
Mitch it's a real guilty they start to
follow the rules man Mitch don't follow
the room is easy now let's talk about
real me right in oh that's right my
amateur bad real bills petitions yep
he's saying it looks like he hasn't been
outside for years
all I got left is this bike real
testament in trouble for a while yeah
I got IRS yes his ex-wives took
everything from me
yes sure did I could pin him he but I
don't know because his kids are in the
crowd yeah
and I want to embarrass him either well
we heard it let him know what yeah what
yeah his kids are in the crowd you fired
him up dude punch it
turn around man Real Deals kind of
coming back on here I just like getting
kids give this kid some hope here
desperate dude real dirtbag do not do
not go near that he's a real dirtbag
look as a paid child support 15 years he
looked sad now he looks at Matt he looks
you fired him up this poor kid yeah I
mean you just keep pressing the same
button over oh I was killed I'm it just
look at first he's looking first kids in
the audience he did they get the teacher
or not here though well now look at him
thrown caution to win here do not lose I
let him win it's really controllers bro
real deal needed it look at him yeah
literally the money throwing caution to
the wind
we're over look at now okay we made him
happy it looks like the guy from Bad
Santa what's his name uh Billy Bob
[Laughter]
looking at the kids yeah we're not we
did get my body feel so blown up get my
bike fueled up yeah
we did it we get a sign
[Music]